to take the temperature of the labour
Tory battle you can't do much better
the go to Blackpool South a Labour held
marginal since 1997 it's stayed true
through the ups and downs in the 20
years since sporting a solid but slender
two and a half thousand majority that
ball is you never quite know when
they're going to fall and what might
charge the tour is over the line in this
one of the UK's most deprived
constituencies what else 5000 glittering
you Kip votes in a constituency which
plumped for leave by a whopping 69
percent margin putting yourself in 1996
one man who's seen Blackpool through
thick and thin is basil Newby local
business impresario and owner of the
infamous funny girls
he thinks the area has had a new lease
of life because of bricks it I think
because we're leaving I think that's
probably a a bonus for Blackpool the
only thing that's gonna be leaving yeah
exactly
I think is leaving it's gonna attract
more tourists yet mainly Tories many
labour in here or you know I make sure
we used to get more than news to have
the little conferences oh oh who did you
have in our yeah every was always
everybody from it goes back yeah I visit
to Blackpool without visits of funny
girls and the pleasure beach she's
Margaret Raja she was a funny girl yeah
wife funny about dopey she was funny
enough to come in for was Theresa Mays
big gamble is that she reconfigures the
electoral sociology of this country by
bringing in working-class leavers many
of whom would never have countenance
voting Tory the only dark spot on that
electoral horizon are people like
warehouse worker Jordan who yes voted
leave but might never vote again I was
with the brexit yeah thought it couldn't
be better once like mmm when we become
like we was hundreds and hundreds of
years ago when we was like the biggest
exporter and a lot of pound don't want
to be a part of something when we can be
great again shall we say and then for
all we're told of how we are a nation
politicized
there are many for whom the votes and
the instability are still rather
a spy Allison to a politician we're
nearly half an hour all night and I
didn't know anymore
okay the monitoring when started Teresa
Mae's Maidenhead feels a long way from
Blackpool yet if the polls are right it
will soon form part of her new electoral
base one which may endure long after
this election has passed Lois could all
Sky News Blackpool